now within the last hour or so we've
been learning of there having been an
earthquake in the far eastern province
of Turkey van right on the border with
Iran the epicenter though of this
earthquake apparently is on the other
side of the border in Iran in a small
village a few kilometres away from the
Turkish border but hashirama Jabara is
our correspondent he's in hat thai
province in southern Turkey what more
can you tell us in about this earthquake
that is affecting at eastern Turkey as
well as western Iran well the
authorities here are saying that eight
people were killed and 21 injured in the
5.7 magnitude earthquake that hit the
areas on the border with Iran
particularly in that province of a van
and the areas particularly affected are
GU velak and ospina now the they also
say that they are concerned many people
are still trapped under the rubble and
the rescue operation is underway we're
talking about an area that's rather on
the border and the authorities and the
rescuers have really to go through all
those villages in the mountainous areas
for them to be able to establish and
gauge the scope and the magnitude of the
damage and those areas are on the border
with Iran and this explains why they are
some of the most seismically active in
the world in last month for example 41
people were killed in an earthquake that
had two provinces in in in the eastern
part of Turkey Eliza and Malatya and
more than a hundred and five hundred
1500 people were injured in that
earthquake the authorities are saying
they are doing their best to try to get
closer to all the areas that are
affected and to ensure that also they
retrieve all those who are still now
buried under the rubble
all right Hashem thank you very much
Hashima hibari they're giving us the
very latest on that earthquake